yeah we have really special guest we
have Anish GE with us I mean Anish hello
welcome to the studio and it's really
nice to see you here again but I felt
today that it was a day of missed
opportunities for you I'm every every
game I was checking you had really good
chances let's start from the beginning
let's go through all the games very
quickly I mean it's also day of Miss
opportunities for my opponent because
every round they're facing me which is
an opportunity and which they kept
missing so it's all relative I think but
um of course I had some uh good good
chances first game of course I was
completely winning at one point I mean
the opening he fell into my trap just
yesterday I realized that H6 is also
very likely here instead of oh this
instead of Queen takes E4 which is the
main move where it's sort of equal with
accurate play but after H6 it's feel
smart yeah but there is this rookie one
rookie one move I like so much you know
now you cannot take on G5 yes and it
took me some time to realize it yest
yeah but I knew that I was expecting
some Queen A3 I thought it was not
so I mean I knew computer gives like uh
right yeah no this is just over so I
thought computer gives this like um some
big plus oh W let's go mhm big plus um
but I mean I wasn't sure during the game
like how bad it is I don't know why he
didn't play Queen A3 he played Rook C8
where I could take on E7 also maybe was
better I missed Bishop D1 and here I
kind of um too much surprise here I
thought he's completely lost but after
Bishop D1 to my surprise was not so
simple the end game also shouldn't have
been so easy if he had played Bishop f8
here and actually it might still be
within for him because the thing is that
he sort of has to control my pawns so
here the problem was that I started
getting obsessed about this idea of
promoting my Pawns of course and I can
understand why yeah you really want he
miss Bishop before the trick is that
after Rook A2 I've got
um oh I already missed uh Rook a one
here because I have D6 and E6 E6 I don't
have because they take Rook a one so I
miss this Rook a one thing everywhere
but D6 here also wins and after A5 okay
he desperate I mean he miss Bishop
before now Bishop F there is also D6
just D7 just so he missed this and um
here I mean I just um just Pro I mean I
go D6 I'm going D7 so he'll go before
and okay of course I understand this
position is completely winning for me
but um I started to think like um you
know it will maybe take a while to
convert I was thinking maybe he'll put
Bishop here I have to Knight E4 is maybe
not say I have to defend this and then
he will attack my Bishop I mean I am
completely winning of course in okay
it's cannot be block but it's just it
will take some time so I thought maybe
uh of course I understand I'm winning
and I normally take this without
thinking but suddenly I thought okay
maybe I just can put him away with E6
and my logic was that he sure of has to
go B4 because I thought E7 is queening
and I missed R A1 everywhere and here um
yeah I just thought okay I have this
position versus the one versus this
position and like this is maybe even
more winning I miss a one everywhere so
I thought that he has to I don't know
threatening like so I thought he might
go Rook B2 or something then I think I
have Rook E4 what what I was thinking
and then I will go E7 Rook F4 Rook f8
like I just Queen my Pawn so I thought
okay it's just winning and then I realiz
yes yeah when when I make this move like
with my hand like I sort of feel like I
I see this bishop on G7 like I open this
diagonal it feels kind of wrong you know
like the the pawn is sort of opening and
then I like yeah but this kind of long
diagonal and Rook a one of course is I
mean Rook A1 is everywhere the problem
so I miss this move like when he played
it this over so it was just like one
move I mean I'm just winning with D6 I
don't know exactly that's what I felt
also yes that you were so winning in
this game and round two I mean against
Napp this crazy game as well yeah that
one was always less one-sided because um
at one point okay I um let's check this
critical moment I think I asked him
after the game if he missed this C4 and
he said of course I missed it so let's
let's maybe show this moment there were
many moment I mean okay I I sort of uh
B6 is not from not from this
uh not from this fairy tale from
something something else um so I don't
know B6 is wasted wasted move so now
when I go B5 um he's just in time to
take on C4 and I have this one trick in
the game where Knight G5 BC that now I
have this B2 in the end so this maybe
what he missed from AAR like this is
like one trick that I have so the whole
thing works out so we have to move a
little bit faster I mean I don't think
we have any
rush you could go Queen A3 which is very
nice because if CB he has got CB and
that's quite nice so he also had missed
some opportunities to be fair C4 C4 yes
this was a critical moment I think after
that you are absolutely winning in this
game yeah I'm winning but not with the
clock that I have I think I had at that
point uh it says four minutes I felt
like I had 10 seconds but maybe I had I
don't think I had four minutes but I
don't know I felt like I had no time at
all and um yeah then I played very badly
so what was the last moment where you
missed this like chances for the the
victory yeah you know just generally I'm
just um I'm just you know the moment I
was born already I think was when things
were getting difficult it was never so
hly like I had like seconds it was never
obvious to me because the problem is
okay I have the extra Pawn but I have a
very bad Knight on G6 it's never easy
long term like so yeah I think Knight B5
was the move I didn't even consider that
move I mean I considered bringing the
Knight to D4 but I thought Knight E7
Knight Knight D4 and um I didn't even
consider Knight B5 and I had no time and
the thing is if white sort of guess King
G2 long longterm I'm a little bit um not
doing as winning as as um shortterm
because my night on G6 is very very bad
so I kind of just um I mean thank you so
much I mean the day was not so bad three
draws but I wish you all the best of
luck in the next rounds and we are going
back to the studio things are getting
crazy thank you uh